joining us now is David corn co-author
of hubris the inside story of spin
scandal and the selling of the Iraq war
and we'll get to discussion about the
book in just a few seconds but first the
lead story in this morning's Washington
Post involves Senator Allen and his
challenger mr. Webb quarreling over the
war in Iraq and bush policies is this
going to be this quarrel about the war
and the policies leading up to the war
and the prosecution of the war is this
going to be a major issue going into or
going through the election in November
well I think what we've seen the last
few weeks that is that Democrats
particularly Jim Webb and Virginia who
worked in the Reagan Defense Department
want to make the handling of the war the
competence of the military leadership
and during the bush years a key issue
Bush wants to talk about terrorism you
know the wiretapping bill and the
military tribunal commission and he was
hoping to pick a fight with Democrats on
that front he ran into a roadblock last
week when it turned out the few leading
Republicans were the ones who were
engaging in the debate well the
Democrats could have laid back and let
John McCain and John Warner and colon
pal take on Bush right i mean if you
look at the polls if you get a sense of
what's having this country now there's a
lot of dismay with bushes handling of
the war in iraq and to the degree to
which a strong democratic candidate can
tie that to a republican candidate for
congress or the house or the Senate that
will help the Democrats so we're going
to see a lot of attempts that each side
trying to reposition and refrain as they
like to say what the election is about
in the next few weeks tell us about the
book hubris the inside story of spin
scandal and the selling of the Iraq war
I'm happy you asked I wrote I corrupt
this book with Michael Isikoff of
Newsweek and it's a narrative book it's
not a polemical book it's the behind the
scenes inside of account of what went on
at the CIA the State Department the
White House the Defense Department and
Congress and they run up to the war all
the intelligence fights that went into
the administration sales campaign for
the war and then it follows what the
White House had to do after the invasion
to preserve its sales campaign because
as we
now no it's two major supporting
arguments that Iraq had WMDs and that
Iraq was connected to al Qaeda
completely fell apart and turned out not
to be true and before the war there are
a lot of people with inside the
intelligence communities and at the
Department of Energy they were arguing
the case that the intelligence wasn't
that strong so we chart all those fights
and you know again it's not a rant we
get behind the scenes and go deep into
the the bureaucracy in some ways this is
almost a an anti Bob Woodward account
and that he often does a top-down view
we get into the guts of the fights and
talk about what was going on at that
level one of the items that seems to be
drawing a lot of attention from this
book is the story of CIA agent Valerie
Plame and how her name came out as a CIA
agent who leaked the name to whom when
tell us about how you report it in your
book yeah there were the reason why we
deal with the leak case to begin with is
because it's a book about the selling of
the war and the leak case kind of came
out after the war because you remember a
few months after the invasion everyone
was saying where are the WMDs and there
was a burgeoning political and policy
dispute about this and they turned out
to be a very vicious in Tunis and
argument within the bush administration
with CIA people leaking to reporters
that our intelligence wasn't as strong
as they made it out to be the State
Department doing the same thing and in
the midst of all this Joe Wilson wrote
his now famous op-ed piece saying that
he had gone Tunisia are for the CIA not
for the State Department to check out
one particular allegation came back and
said it was bunk yet still the president
had used it or referred to it in his
State of the Union address and then
eventually Valerie Plame's name was
leaked in a bob novak column two big
mysteries that remained from that
episode were who was Bob Novak's first
source he had to he's always said he had
there was two and we knew that karl rove
had been the confirming source about who
was the first one in the other big
mystery was what Valerie Plame did at
the CIA a lot of conservatives who
wanted to diminish the significance of
the leak said
she was just an analyst just a paper
pusher even Novak had reported that so
our book reports answers to both of
those questions one was the first one
was the dick Armitage the number two
fellow at the State Department was Bob
Novak's first source and we go into all
the details about how that meeting came
to be and and how it came to be that he
leaked that information how he came to
have that information to leakin and of
course a lot of defenders of the white
us now have have embraced that side of
the reporting of this book to say well
see it wasn't a White House campaign to
get Joe Wilson the book clearly depicts
that there are two things going on at
once you can't have one without the
other I suppose you can it's called
cherry-picking and we've seen a lot of
that but um so we say well Armitage was
meeting with Novak karl rove and scooter
libby and others in the White House were
very set on undermining Joe Wilson's
credibility and in the context of doing
that they also leaked karl rove
confirmed it to novak he leaked it or
independently to Matt Cooper of time and
scooter libby leaked it to judy miller
before novak met with armitage and then
he confirmed it to Matt Cooper you
almost need a diagram here and all this
happened before the Novak leak came out
and if Novak hadn't done his leaked Time
magazine then would have been the first
so it's just kind of a twist of fate the
Norman age ended up being the first and
Novak ended up being the first time
magazine try to get it out and there was
a disagreement about whether it should
appear that in that week's issue and
then I'm the valerie plame side of the
coin here we report that she wasn't a
nano analyst she was chief of operations
for the Joint Task Force on Iraq which
is part of the counter proliferation
division which is part of the Operations
Directorate of the CIA that's the secret
side of the CIA she was at its kind of
highly ironic her job was to run
espionage operations spying stuff not
analysis to try to gather intelligence
on Iraq's WMD programs it was her
mission to find the evidence to justify
Bush's war of course she and her
colleagues found none because there was
nothing to be found but that was the
person who ended up being outed by Dick
Armitage car oven Scooter Libby
now on Friday we had a Robert Novak on
the program and he had a few things to
say about you and your reporting we're
going to run that clip and then give you
a chance to respond I appreciate that
mr. mr. corn is a nasty piece of work
but let me tell you that and that he was
the one who really built this story up
here is an aide what I think is a
deliciously ironic situation because he
was one of the people much more I
believed and chris matthews for building
the story up and they at the outset he
was as i said he was advising joe wilson
which he never puts in his in his column
and he is in the position where i think
mostly through investigative work done
by his partner mr. mr. Isikoff I he is
really a party to breaking down the
story and making it appear there was no
conspiracy at all which must much
actually destroy him David corn your
response well let me just use that to
plug my website because I have a longer
response there I don't want to bore the
viewers here but that's David corn calm
but we run through this a little bit one
clip that you didn't show was that uh he
called me in a ideologue a left-wing ida
log and i have to say and all due
respect to to Bob who I used to like
going on crossfire with that to be
called an idol AAG by bob novak it's
sort of like being called a cheat by
Jack Abramoff I mean the fact that he
can call anybody an idol agha challenge
their reporting it's kind of laughable
but you know he called me a nasty piece
of work all the people decide for
themselves how nasty i am but you know
he noted it was ironic that our book
revealed dick Armitage well it's only
ironic if you as i said earlier
cherry-pick and don't pay attention to
the other sections of the book that
actually expand the narrative about what
karl rove and scoot Olivia doing
actually in today's of Style section of
the Washington Post howard kurtz talks a
little bit about how Scooter Libby was
obsessed with chris matthews and his
sighting of joe wilson believing that
chris matthews was was doing this in an
anti-semitic fashion so we get behind
the scenes and even show that scooter
libby for one was more obsessed with the
whole Joe Wilson
ugly oh then I think people believe he
said I was advising Joe Wilson no I mean
I don't know where he even gets that
from he's just sort of making that up
and he says my partner you know got all
the investigative work well if he thinks
and he's very kind michael is a tough
who is my partner but if he thinks mike
is a great investigative reporting
reporter which he is then he also has to
credit the other parts of the book such
as what we found out about karl rove and
scooter libby that doesn't fit into his
narrative and the fact again that there
was no conspiracy in the White House I
don't think anyone ever said there was a
conspiracy I said there was a campaign
and to get Joe Wilson or 10 to minus
credibility and also you know what
patrick fitzgerald in a court filing in
last April said exactly the same thing
there was a campaign to discredit punish
or seek revenge against Joe Wilson and
he cited high white House officials so I
mean I I just wish Bob would read the
book and and report it honestly you
mentioned that you did have a chance to
respond on your website and believe the
posting was made earlier yesterday
evening around eight o'clock and the
title is Bob Novak slimed me if you want
to read that you can go to david corn
calm meantime we're going to take calls
the numbers are there on the screen then
our first call comes from Columbus
Nebraska you're on the washington
journal with david corn good morning
good morning sir this is why we love
c-span may I ask you dig Nicholas
Kristof cyrill New York piece his source
say that he worked for Cheney's office
or was sent to nigera a Chinese office
or the vice president's office was that
source joe wilson and why do i have a
tape from c-span of joe wilson d 9 he
told nicholas kristof that he was the
source that was sent by Dick Cheney's
office and why didn't mr. Wilson retract
that if Nicholas Kristof got that
original piece wrong that started this
whole affair and didn't Cheney have to
try to find out if his office sent this
joe wilson fella wasn't that the reason
for all of this
well I haven't seen that sees fan club
and I'm not here to be jel Wilson's
defender if you want him i usually don't
get sources correcting stories written
by reporters but you know you can you
can put that question to Nick Kristof
then what happened was the important
thing is what happened in the story what
happened was the we go through this
chapter 5 that uh an intelligence report
came in it was it was from the Italians
in February of 2002 or early 2002 and it
said we have the we have evidence of a
deal of a deal that Iraq was buying
yellowcake uranium from the impoverished
african nation of news year this year
dick cheney was so you know in the weeds
on the intelligence about matters
related to rock he saw this report and
he and he told his briefers he wanted
see I briefers he wanted more
information as we detail on the book and
this isn't all that controversial the CI
briefer went back to the CIA and said
let's get more information to for the
vice president and when the vice
president or president asked for
something the CIA usually snaps to and
the request went to the counter
proliferation division which is where
the joint task force in Iraq where
Valerie Plame worked as part of and they
decided what we got to get more
information for the vice president
everyone knew that the vice president
had put this request forward and out of
that a meeting was held and Joe Wilson
who two years earlier three years
earlier had been used by the division on
a similar task senton easier to find out
information about AQ Khan the infamous
nuclear weapons proliferator out of
Pakistan and on the suggestion someone
came to Valerie Wilson and said can you
bring your husband and will we be
interested in helping us again on this
so the question it's there it's not a
dispute that the trip came about in
response to a request from the vice
president and if you read Joe Wilson's
New York Times op-ed piece it sort of
started everything you know the first
time when he put things out in the
public square I believe he says I don't
have it in front of me that he was
stunned in response to requests from the
vice president and neo if it comes out
in the newspaper or the vice president
certainly has the right to ask anybody
inside the government for more
information and any gay
then matter and as we know from the
investigation the patrick fitzgerald on
in early june of 2003 once wilson has
spoken off the record to a few reporters
Dick Cheney is asking himself the CIA
for information on Joe Wilson finds out
that his wife works at the counter
proliferation division which you might
assume would be a classified position
since it's a secretive unit and he tells
that information the scooter libby
they're perfectly within their rights to
ask these questions and find out the
information the whole dispute is whether
you can then start leaking this in order
to undermine a policy critic let's go to
Miami Florida on our line supporting
President Bush good morning yeah I Novak
in his riddle column using word
operative and it was kind of common
college / Hugh ciety that playing worked
CIA information in Wilson's books showed
that she was not covered under the
statute make people say she was outed by
the Pollard investigation but you were
the first journalist to use the word
covert and so it makes a lot of people
think that maybe you had information
from someplace else so my question is
what was your relationship to will
complain prior to your article did you
have conversations with you know what
were those and number two were you ever
caught by Fitzgerald before the grand
jury oh well second second question is
no not at all I wish I had I would have
gotten some good copy out of it Matt
Cooper and other he's got wonderful
pieces out of being called before the
grand jury on the first question there
people can go on the website to there's
a canard that's been advanced by some of
my old friends on the right that I'm the
one who really outed Valerie Plame
because to day two days after the Novak
piece r and Bob Novak called her a CIA
operative working on WMD issues which
has actually a pretty good description
given that our book now reveals she was
chief of operations for the joint task
force in Iraq focusing on Iraqi WMD
issues so he says she's an operative two
days afterwards I write a piece noting
that this leak is he decided to
administration sources that this leak
could be could be a violation of the
intelligence identity
Protection Act and I say that if it's
true under the peace keep saying if
Novak has it right if his sources are
giving him the accurate information then
she was probably a covert undercover
operative because if this is a very
simple point that's being twisted here
because she was telling family members
that she was an energy analyst if you
work for the CIA in operations in bob
novak called her an operative there are
two types of cover i hope this isn't too
much details here if it is Rob just cut
me off there are two types of cover one
is called official cover you go overseas
you tell people you work at the State
Department or you work for the Defense
Department you work out at the embassy
and you're really working for the CIA
that means if you get into any trouble
you have a diplomatic passport and you
can get you know run to the embassy be
whisked out of the country no fuss no
muss now if you have non-official cover
you walk around you tell people you're a
business person you're our tour guide
you're an author you know you're a bon
vivant whatever you pretend to be
whatever your cover is and you often you
even work those jobs and you and you
live live your cover so if you go around
telling people in Washington if you meet
someone they say they work at the State
Department you know they could work at
the city harder they might work at the
CIA but if you tell some of your an
energy department excuse me a private
energy analyst but you do work at the
CIA it means you have non-official cover
which is more sensitive covered so my
piece said that she would if if Novak
was right and I know I allowed for the
possibility that even Bob Novak gets his
facts around once in a while but if the
piece was right that had to mean she was
undercover that had to mean them that
administration officials were outing an
undercover operative who worked on WMD
issues and i just find it bizarre that
anyone could make the argument that
after bob novak calls her a CIA
operative and do there's a CI a-- have
it have any non secret operatives have
you ever met a non secret public CIA
operative I've worked this beat for 20
years I wrote a book on the CI and I
never have so after he calls her CIA
operative and appears in hundreds of
newspapers and websites around the
country
her covered is loan next up is bella
vista arkansas you're on with david corn
good morning yes good morning I think
the greatest example of hubris in this
country in the past five or six years
has been the media's response when we
were getting ready to be in lockstep so
that we could go beat up on our rack
because I don't think I saw enough
information that refuted the
administration's view about the weapons
of mass destruction and their alliance
with al-qaeda the only place that I saw
any that the information that I needed
to make up my mind about the Iraq war
was in Newsweek and it was one sixteenth
of a page and it was a their interview
with the German diplomat who said that
Germany knew that they did not have
weapons of mass destruction but they
could not say that for one hundred
percent I never saw that written any
place else and since then I have gotten
rid of time which I took for 30 years I
got rid of US News and World Report when
they supported Bush for president in two
thousand and thanks man we're gonna have
to let it go I my colleague who corrupt
the book with me michael is a cough up
Newsweek would have been very happy to
hear that caller um she's making a
really important point and our book goes
into great detail about this we talked
about the how the media sort of dropped
the ball some key stories and a lot of
people blame only Judith no of New York
Times we show other examples of that but
what's important is we note that on all
the key elements practically all the key
elements of the WMD case for war and the
connection between al-qaeda and Saddam's
Bruno regime that there
people within the intelligence
bureaucracy who were questioning these
things and who would you know pushing
back internally and some of this did
spill out into the media there were some
leaks they were there was some coverage
for instance after the after dick cheney
you know held up in New York Times front
page story instead that the New Times is
reporting that there were aluminum tubes
being bought by Iraq that could only be
used for a nuclear weapons program there
was a piece in The Washington Post that
noted that all the top department of
energy experts didn't buy this case and
that it was disputed that piece appeared
on something like page a17 of the
Washington Post and The Times didn't
pick up on it no one else picked up on
it but it was a case the reporter had
gotten a glimpse on this very hotly
contested debate within the intelligence
community and it was kind of um I think
a journalistic crime for the for the
post itself not to follow through on
that but you know they at least gave it
a shot The Times and others not to
follow through on that and we detail how
those stories came and went in this book
if deputy secretary of state Armitage
leaked Valerie Plame's name to Robert
Novak what difference does it make what
Rove and Libby may or may not have told
matt cooper or judith miller well that's
a good question you know the narrative
has been that the White House was out to
get discredit undermine whatever
language you want to use gel Wilson and
as I as a as part of that they I view it
as the political campaign it's not too
far stretch to see karo viewing it as a
political campaign in fact we have a
scene in the book where he calls Chris
Matthews of hardball and says the
Wilsons are screwing us we're going to
screw the Wilsons now you know some
Americans might find that offensive that
the highest advisor to the White House
in the White House of the present United
States that's using that type of
terminology some people might just say
oh of course that happens all the time
don't forget that Novak excuse me that
rove himself confirmed the information
to bob novak i bob novak was always said
there were two sources i assume that he
would not have run this story on one
source so
grohe had a key played a key role there
but it goes to the issue of whether they
weren't involved in the week another
thing that people forget is that Patrick
Fitzgerald was investigating not the
Novak column but the leak and Time
magazine ran the same information a day
or two later and they almost beat Novak
to the punch but didn't so he was also
investigating the leaking to Time
magazine which was Karl Rove's leak and
as you remember the president and the
White House very ostentatiously said at
the beginning the leak was terrible
anybody involved would be fired so it's
a question of integrity that it turned
out that karl rove was involved there's
an email from Matt Cooper that proves he
was involved there's no denying that and
yet the White House you know backed off
from that vow now according to your
reporting and others the vice president
met with members of the Joint Task Force
on Iraq to see what they were doing you
know in in order to try and find
evidence of weapons of mass destruction
OTT he didn't not that he met with
members of the Joint Task Force in Iraq
he did go out to Langley to meet with
analysts he met with members of the
Iraqi operation of the rock operations
group but a little different so never
anybody from jtf I as far as I know
never you know I don't think they
between him and Valerie Plame would have
been quite dramatic no but the beginning
of the book we have a scene in which he
goes out to Langley to where the CIA is
based and he meets with these fellows
who go who are who are put together this
is this extensive covert action program
called Project and a basis which was
designed to do assassination and
sabotage inside Iraq as a prelude to war
and also perhaps to create a provocation
that would allow the US and Britain to
come into rock and kick off the invasion
and in the course of doing that he also
met with analysts at the CIA and they
have to ask them questions about WMDs
but was striking well all the questions
that he asked was not whether Saddam had
WMDs and how much of a threat he was
could he be contained in other ways it
was what which of his military units had
what type of WMDs and how
might they be used in a war so he had
already decided that war was likely and
he didn't need to know about whether
Saddam was a WMD threat he just assumed
he was in addition to writing books like
hubris david corn is also an editor with
the nation and he writes on a host of
subjects including politics the White
House Congress and national security
establishment and he has an item in this
this week's edition of the nation aptly
titled the Valerie Plame's role at the
CIA this is a continuation of the the
discussion yeah we're sort of it was a
modified excerpt of the book okay on the
book back to the phones and Tulsa
Oklahoma you're on with David corn go
ahead good morning gentlemen I'm gonna
bring good things real quick it just
slays me when I hear individuals like
mr. corn I mean they they've gotten
extremely rich bash and Bush all these
years okay now i'ma wait a second I'd
like you to see my bank account in my
mortgage and everything i'm far from
extremely rich I don't complain but
believe me I am NOT extremely rich
richer enriched your career okay okay
fine and and the thing that I can't
understand i've got the statement than a
question the thing that I can't
understand is you know who cares about
Valerie Plame out here in flyover
country which I'm sure folks like
yourself you know don't get out here
this often we don't sit around the
coffee shops we don't sit around the
cafes discussing the government's
involvement in outing a Valerie flame I
mean I just I don't get it and secondly
for all you people that like to to blame
bush critique bush in the administration
on the war in Iraq and how it's been
handled how would you treat it how would
you handle the Warner wreck we're there
okay so we need to get over how we got
there we r there and I want to hear you
run as a reporter what would you what
would your exit strategy be okay let me
take on your first point you don't want
to care about you know the outing of a
CIA officer that's certainly your
prerogative you don't care about the way
the White House responds to policy
critics and what's supposed to be in an
open democracy you don't have to I mean
you can think about something else
there's a lot
worried about our book that I wrote with
mike is the cough is not just about the
leak case it's about the sales campaign
of that went into the Iraq war and all
these other matters that we've been
discussing today and how the leak case
came out of that I happen to think that
how this administration presented its
case for is a is the historic episode
and why think we'll be poked and probed
and explored and written about for
decades to come and I'm glad that
Michael Isikoff and I have gotten off
you know one of the first I think
comprehensive accountings of what
happened as opposed you know I listen I
understand you know this this this line
of argument from bush defenders what
would you do now but you know the way I
look at this is it before the war there
are lots of people out there we said you
know don't hit that was never nest with
a stick you know don't go in there
particularly you don't have a good plan
particularly don't have support around
the world and you know do you have a
good case here can you do this will be
difficult you know Donald run so wanting
to do this originally was seventy
thousand troops and he had to be talked
up to 200,000 troops paul woolford said
this could be self-funded with with with
oil reconstruction money and they all
laughed at general Shinseki when he when
he said you need hundreds of thousands
of troops afterwards so a lot of people
looked at what they were saying at the
time and said this doesn't make sense
don't do this so when people then go
ahead and do something that you're there
warned not to do and they do it poorly
and incompetently and silly don't meet
their own standards you know it's kind
of unfair to come to the people say you
shouldn't have done this and say well
what would you do now well the question
you know the answer is well we you know
we wouldn't have made a mess but anyway
they'd sort of you know I'm not a policy
maker i don't i'm not running for office
i'm not on the ballot but I it seems
clear to me that the Bush administration
has not done much to reverse its you
know it's its previous mistakes only by
just keeping the same team in place i'm
donald rumsfeld is still there and i
find it interesting that in Israel there
was a war lasted thirty three days much
much of the public was dissatisfied with
how the war was conducted and there's
already talk of an independent committee
they'll have the ability to fire people
you know to made mistakes in that war
and yet here we see the same team in
charge and I see Vice President Cheney
you know who a year ago said that the
insurgency was in its last throes still
defending remarks like that Adam oh if
you know I would I would think about
changing the team and bringing in new
people and get new ideas on what to do
there we have this email from Roseanne
and Gardner New York she writes why did
the New York Times continue to allow
Judith Miller long after a reports
proved inaccurate and why did New York
Times support her for so long afterwards
you know we have a lot in the book about
Judith Miller what happened at the New
York Times and again she was not the
only one who fell for the fraudulent
intelligence much of it which is brought
to her and other reporters by the Iraq
National Congress and just as an aside
in the book we talked to see I officers
who told us that the fellow at the Iraq
National Congress which was run by
Achmed Chalabi who is in charge of
bringing information to members of the
administration the vice president's
office and two members of the media like
Judith Miller that person in charge of
that was suspected of the CIA of working
with Iranian intelligence being an
Iranian intelligence asset meaning that
the guy in charge of trying to change
public opinion in America for the I NC
to get the public in behind the war
might have been working hand in hand in
hand with Iranian intelligence when we
would tell this and one fellows on
record 1 CI officers telling us this I
was flabbergasted I so what did you do
internally at the I at the CIA did you
go to the White House did you you know
tell people anything about this he
shrugged its shoulders and said well you
know we didn't do much because you can't
fight city hall meaning that the White
House and the Defense Department was so
in bed with the eye and see that they
didn't they wouldn't listen and the same
thing was true with Judy Miller at the
new york times we have emails from her
in our book when she says that they're
all that her front page stories in The
Times and WMDs you know while all base
were mostly based on sources they came
from the Achmed
Shalaby and the senate intelligence
report that came out two weeks ago now
you know shows that all that was just
pure fabrication why the time stuck with
her is sort of like the way the Y dust
is stuck with this case you know gotten
got in deep on this and then there was
the Jayson Blair meltdown and the Bill
Keller came in a new editor and just
didn't want to look back didn't want to
deal with this and took a year for him
to deal with Judy Miller and the times
bad reporting in WMDs this is from
Kilvert Ohio Anna rights mr. corn why
have reporters Bob Woodward and Robert
Novak and also attorney Victoria thanh
Singh made such public efforts to
undermine Patrick Fitzgerald's
investigation of this leak they have
publicly said that this investigation is
much to do much to do about nothing and
blown out of proportion what are they
trying to do when will we find out how
this leak affected national security
well we still don't know there's never
been any public accounting of what
damage if any was done by the outing of
Valerie Wilson you know she was
undercover for a number of years you
went around the world she met with
people she her job as we talked about in
the book was before the joint task force
in Iraq a few years before that was
recruiting and spotting agents and spies
for the CIA so presumably other
countries are the foreign intelligence
services put her name through their
computer listings and try to find out
contacts that she might have had so it's
conceivable it's conceivable that people
agents and operations might have been
blown but we don't know the details on
that why Victoria ton Singh and Bob
Novak and are undermining Patrick
Fitzgerald you know I don't know I
haven't on the show and a sky I think
it's me it's because these are
well-known defenders of the White House
and you know Bob Novak and Karl Rove go
back years there's that story from 10 20
25 years ago when when Rove got fired
from a tech moment from Bush the first
president bush's a presidential campaign
for leaking to bob novak so a lot of
things don't change and Victoria ton sig
is the Republican lawyer who's taking
shots at me as well I'm so I'll be
modest here but she certainly you know
has an interest in
protecting Karl Rove the interesting
thing is Bob Woodward because you know
he was out there attacking and you know
and criticizing the the Special Counsel
while sitting on this big secret that
dig harmony to tell him the same thing
now there's always good reasons for
reporters night mixed feelings about
this too about Fitzgerald because he was
locking up other reporters for not
revealing the sources so Bob would would
like myself and Mike is a cuff and
others you know had reasons to you know
be worried about this but at the same
time he was you know trying to undermine
or criticize the Special Counsel he was
also protecting one of the targets of
the Special Counsel the garbage so I
think and he got into trouble for that I
think that the wise course of action
would have been to turn down those
requests to go on Larry King Live and
pontificate and just keep his powder dry
and Fridays wall street journal in the
op-ed section Victoria taunting wrote a
piece what a load of Armitage is the
title and in it she writes buy his
silence mr. Armitage is responsible for
one of the most factually distorted
investigations in history well I still
defy her to say what facts you know
Patrick Fitzgerald distorted who got
wrong when he know he was very I think
you know it restrained in his press
conference when he said that this is the
IE was in diving school would be for
lying now Victoria Thompson used to work
at the Justice Department she is a
lawyer in town here I don't does she and
do others who now say there is nothing
to this investigation countenance high
government officials likely allegedly
lying or committing perjury when FBI
agents and special councils try to
question them I mean that's a good
question they asked that I put that to
Bob Novak as well peoria illinois on our
others line thank you very much for
waiting go right ahead i think a lot of
us consider this valerie plame case
water inside the beltway gossip
Washington politics got your stuff and
we need to look at more of the excuses
that using a pretext for war going back
to the first Gulf War there was that
case where the country was very evenly
split and they try to push it through
Congress to use force by talking about
babies being kicked out of incubators in
Kuwait and that was a total fabrication
put
other public relations firm in
Washington and is really the daughter of
the Kuwaiti ambassador was saying that
it was a total lie and fabrication
pushed us over the top and Goddess
involved the first Gulf War there was
the CIA analyst shutting his name was
Charles pelletier were top head in New
York Times saying that they some of the
same couldn't possibly guess occurs the
gas was based on cyanine that type of
technology was only available to ran and
I ran is the one that gas the Kurds
there's Newsweek story that the generals
were warned ahead of time about
canceling their flights carried twice
and Newsweek and never took traction in
the country there's that is I director
Massoud who ordered Saeed Sheikh to wire
a hundred thousand dollars to Mohamed
Atta before the 911 is the airlift and
condos in November of 2001 thousands of
al-qaeda and Taliban out of out of
Afghanistan where they were surrounded
into Pakistan four days for almost two
weeks the OREA thanks for the list mr.
corn well he was talking about what
would I be for the first Gulf War and
some of the theories that have been put
up about 911 will mean that's not part
of a part of our book or book but that
our book does look at the campaign that
went into convincing the public of the
need to go to Warren and there was this
you know very tight intersection between
the White House and the media and
misusing you know pieces of intelligence
that were not nearly as solid as they
kept saying any I make we make this
point in the book that if the president
and vice president wanted to come out
and say Saddam Hussein's a bad guy which
of course he was and is a potential
problem to us and everybody's it was a
potential problem we're not sure what he
has when I'm sure of this connected with
al Qaeda but we're not going to take any
chances and we want to go to war on the
basis of this imperfect knowledge that
would have at least been an honest
debate there would be no no one could
have criticized that then you decide
what is the level of information that
you decide to invade another country
upon but what they did was it was say
there was president said there was no
doubt about intelligence the other vice
president waved these aluminum tubes
when there was tremendous debate about
that we now know the intelligence and
the al-qaeda connect
was was weak in fact some intelligence
reports said there was no connection and
so it was that type of sales campaign
and make their case solid that I think
has gotten them into the problems the
political problems they have today next
up is leonardtown Maryland good morning
good morning I'm real interested in your
answer to this actually Valerie Plame
was outed by alder James and had not
been a undercover agent sense alder
James had added her along with quite a
few other people and also joe wilson
supposedly was brought up three times
for questions on his going to check out
the yellowcake uranium and was actually
told that he lied and he lied for a
reason he lied because of how he wanted
the information to come out to the world
not what the truth was and thanks man
well I have no idea what you're talking
about he was brought up three times then
he lied i would just refer you to the
new york times off-peak our bed peace
that he wrote because there i don't
think there's any you know factual in
the statements that people pointed out
on order james it's an interesting point
we'd go into this in the book there was
some thinking that Otto James who was of
course the spy within the CIA for the
Soviet Union on that he that he revealed
he was on some promotion boards inside
the CIA so he knew the names of a lot of
CIA officers and there were some
thinking that perhaps he might have
revealed her name to to the Russians
it's still unclear whether or not that
did indeed happen and but even so even
so you know there are a lot there are a
lot of people whose names he might have
revealed but if it's revealed just you
know to the Russians and not to the
world at large that's a lot different
type of blowing cover then then would be
if you put someone its name up publicly
Valerie you know Valerie Plame Wilson at
the time of her outing was was was still
a non-official cover CIA operative she
was working in the CIA headquarters a
lot of people confuse
point I don't excuse me there are a lot
of officers working at the CIA who are
still undercover they go there each day
yes they make the you know the commute
across the Potomac River from their
suburban homes but they're still
undercover the fact that Washington Post
often refers to officials at the CIA
high-level officials whose names are
undercover and they don't give the names
out of respect to that and she was
making the transition from non-official
cover to official cover with a
distinction that we talked about earlier
and she had traveled overseas as part of
her Joint Task Force on Iraq duties so
she was still an operations officer
under-covered traveling overseas despite
whatever it happened with with alder
James who is Douglas Ronan what's his
what's how does he figure into all of
this you get that gets into another one
these detailed parts of the plane case
one charge that the the Wilson critics
have made is that Valley Wilson sent her
husband on this trip in fact the vice
president wrote on his op-ed piece when
it came out did you know did she send
him on a boondoggle or a junket that
somehow this was a nepotistic venture
which would undermine Wilson standing to
go on this trip you know he had then you
know he had worked in Nigeria issues
Nigerian issues he had served there and
he actually as a businessman had dealt
with uranium issues in her in Africa so
he was on the few people in town who
knew something about uranium in Africa
and something about news year so he was
more qualified than people give him
credit for so the the charges that she
sent him on this trip and that would
that undermines his his expertise that
was based on a State Department memo
that said that she convened the meeting
that he went to the CIA that led to the
trip that meeting that those notes of
that meeting web-based let me start to
get that memo was based on notes taken
at that meeting by an eye on our state
Department analyst named Doug roan his
note said I want
to this meeting it was apparently
convened not convened apparently
convened by Joe Wilson's wife who is a
WMD manager the CIA now there's a whole
chain of events that led to his
apparently convened turning into
convened all inadvertent it was that
memo that landed on armitage his desk
when she read you know what she knew
about when he talked to Novak could also
went to scooter libby into others they
picked up and they said all that meant
she sent him I talked to Doug grown for
the book and I said can you explain this
and you know it took weeks for him to
get say anything and he was very loath
he still works at the State Department
and I'm eventually he said that he used
the word apparently convened because he
wasn't sure he entered the meeting wait
Valerie Wilson was not at the meeting he
said he's never met value Wilson that
was his impression but now he realizes
and he says that he may have created one
gigantic misimpression by putting in
those words apparently convened so uh
it's Theo a big hullabaloo created by
what might have been a completely
accidental slip is it possible that the
basis of this whole Joe Wilson Valerie
Plame episode was just something that
was created by a misinterpretation by
Douglas rom well the charge that he was
sent as a on a boondoggle by his wife
you know his wife's key involvement in
this you know which some people make a
big deal out of that is based a lot on
this foundation of an inadvertent
sentence just one sentence our last call
for David corn comes from West River
Maryland good morning good morning I
have two questions the first question is
I read an article in vanity fair
magazine which discussed a group of kind
of shady characters in Italy who whose
purpose was to create false intelligence
for other countries and according to
that article this was the group that
broke into the Niger embassy
in Italy and nothing missing except the
stationary and the initial mailing stand
and I wondered if our guests whose book
I can't wait to read knows anything
about that and the second question is
I'd like to know mr. corns opinion of
this group of Americans we have in our
country today who were so willing to
[ __ ] the Clinton administration over
a gentleman's lie and who are now so
willing to live in complete denial over
an administration who tries to change
laws so that they can get cover for
breaking man and who lies to us about
something so important ascending our
young people to die well I think you
stated your opinion quite strongly there
and let me just go to the first point
that you raised the case of the knees
are documents we go into this in great
length in the book and try to trace back
the origins and all we talked to federal
investigators who do believe that these
documents originated at least big
distort as a financial con you create
these documents and you could sell them
to intelligence services we talked to
high officials of French intelligence
where the documents came to them and
they selected and they laughed at them
is they're not going to pay you anything
for this and we break a lot of new
ground on this and the thing that's
interesting to me about that ho episode
and one thing that hasn't gotten a lot
of attention is that those documents
came into the State Department almost
here 810 months following the sea-ice
reporting to the vice president and two
others that we have intelligence about
this deal and those documents came in
and they were they were fraudulent you
know they easily determined to be untrue
if you started googling them as I listed
later but they also also came attached
to them was a document calling for a
gathering a union of rogue state a rogue
state alliance between Iran Iraq I think
Somalia Sudan
all these anti-us come countries that
would get together and form a dark
secret alliance it was really something
out of austin powers or i owe our smersh
smirch from the old James Bond movies
and one sharp analyst a guy named Simon
Dodge why don't I think the heroes of
the book saw that document and said this
is patently absurd since it came with
the same stamps and signatures as the
Niger deal documents he realized that
that had to be a hoax and a phony too
and so right away from the get-go he
started saying there's nothing to this
but yet somehow it made it to the
President's speech and it led to the
whole jill wilson imbroglio david corn
co-author of hubris the inside